welcome to this edition of the into the
impossible podcast today i've got deepak
chopra
why would i have deepak chopra on the
into the impossible podcast well you're
about to find out
he's been called many things most of
which are not very kind and befitting of
him
but i found him to be incredibly
intelligent brilliant even
in his explication of what it means to
be human and
even what he calls meta-human we talked
about a few things today that will
really blow your mind as it did for me
including what his daily routine is how
he has achieved such a stunning success
materially and otherwise we'll also talk
about what he calls the four
phases of life and how that has helped
him
confront the anxiety of his eventual
death
and finally we'll talk about ways that
he believes
that are backed by nobel prize lead
research
here in the san diego area that life can
be
extended through some of the tools which
he
provides on this episode and that
includes
ways to think about uh meditation and
contemplation
as a practice and last but not least
you'll get to hear
how deepak upgraded 10xed
my previous mantra from tm
transcendental meditation
from the original one that i got which
was shmuck uh to
a new one you'll have to tune in to the
end to find out what that is you're
gonna enjoy this ride with none of them
deepak chopra
you won't want to miss how he describes
how he's perceived by other scientists
like me
but he is an incredibly uh intelligent
cheerful humble human being and i
greatly enjoyed this episode i know you
will too please share comments in the
uh links below uh please subscribe to
the into the impossible podcast and i'm
looking forward to having him
and his colleague don hoffman and
leonard milad now
uh on again as well as frank wilcheck
winner of the nobel prize you hear shout
out
to frank wilcheck from deepak and their
collaboration together
will uh convince you if nothing else
will uh that deepak is to be taken
seriously even by so-called serious
scientists like myself anyway
sit back enjoy this episode i know
you're gonna love it
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic today i want to welcome
a very special guest to the into the
impossible podcast
it's a friend of mine a friend of the
arthur c clark center for human
imagination and it's deepak chopra
and you may wonder why as brian keating
a professor of physics
an astrophysicist talking to deepak
chopra
i mean deepak do you know what
physicists tell me when i tell them i'm
talking to deepak chopra do you have any
idea what they might say
pseudoscientist [ __ ]
what else profound uh
profound crap
that's incredulous yes exactly but i
always tell them i know no one else who
has
is as intellectually honest as you and
i say that from years of knowing you and
observing you
as an observer although you're going to
tell me if my observations are biased in
any way
but to all the people out there all the
physicists that are snarking and turning
off this interview
uh you're really doing yourself harm
because uh what deepak has to teach us
is incredibly profound and you might not
agree with his
with his conclusions but i ask you to
trust me if i've gleaned any credibility
for you and you're still watching this
video
after 30 seconds of this disclaimer you
will learn a lot about
the most important attribute of a
scientist and that's humility
and i think deepak we live in a uh in a
simultaneous superposition
of science and scientism where we
sort of worship science and we all think
we know what science means
but as as i often point out we really
don't have
a universal definition of science and i
call that
the hard problem of of consciousness
because the awareness of science is at
an all-time low whereas our technology
and our ability to damage other people
is at an all-time high
so today i want to talk to you about uh
the the impact that you've had on me
which is really through
your written word and uh and also uh
having spoken with you on numerous
occasions i should point out that
i'm basically the lowest level of your
uh
physics support there are people by the
name of sir roger penrose
who is a big booster of deepak chopra
there's a man by the name of
leonard milad now who once challenged
deepak
at caltech with the very same
accusations that you just heard him
level at himself
and who is one of your closest
collaborators these days deepak
write down menas kapatos who's a
physicist
he used to be at berkeley and then he
was a chaplain he's
from mit that's where he trained and god
is phd from mit and minas is a
very interesting man who of course is a
proponent of
the john boyenman
[Music]
copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics which places him
also in the conservation position right
now but
he's also very spiritual and we we
together
go to spiritual retreats and the other
colleague i was referring to is leonard
malott now who uh not only
endorsed this book you are the universe
we'll be talking about this book today
but he also co-wrote a book with you uh
called were
two books war of the world views and uh
and another book about science and and
god um i found them very
duplicative though uh teapot why is that
why
why are there two books written by you
and leonard
no no there's only one book i think
paperback
yes i'm joking it has a different title
in the uk
and that's the one that i i also read so
i'm just joking about that but the other
person who's become a very close
associate
of deepak so much so that he asked
deepak to endorse his book
is uh none other than this man
former guest on the into the impossible
uh podcast frank wilcheck
now if anyone wants to call frank we'll
check full of you know what
uh i think they've got their work cut
out for them so deepak said of this book
for a century science has invalidated
soft questions about truth beauty and
transcendence
it took some considerable courage for
frank wilcheck to declare such questions
are within the framework of hard science
and that's sort of what you do i see you
as as a bridge
between uh the notion of science and
scientism
as sort of a cure-all and and as arthur
c clark the patron
namesake of our organization here at uc
san diego
he said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
and what is technology if not applied
science and so therefore
i think we live in an age where science
is almost worshipped and
what do you make of that deepak is there
opening question what do you think of
the
esteem that science is held in you're an
md
you're not a traditional research
scientist uh the way that say i am or
frank wilcheck is
but what do you make of of the pedestal
in which science finds itself these days
i think science is the biggest
adventure that human beings have taken
ever and it's the scientific revolution
is only 500 years
old which is nothing
compared to our life on this planet
which is over 200 000
years as homo sapiens and of course
compared to life on our planet other
than human
and the agricultural revolution occurred
12 000 years ago
the so-called cognitive revolution when
humans started
making up stories um and the first
stories were gossip
basically which are still the most
dominant stories of humankind
but then that led to other stories
mythology
religion and then an explanation of
those stories
theology philosophy and now we have
science
and science as i said only 500 years of
that
the major breakthroughs in science maybe
since newton
and you know descartes at that time the
so-called european enlightenment but in
the last 100 years
science has actually made such
breakthroughs
that make this conversation possible
right
make it possible for us to send probes
into intergalactic space
makes it possible for us through
biological sciences to understand the
workings of the human body that's
what i am a physician and by the way we
do
do research at ucsd
we are looking at the biological
correlates of
consciousness and we published a lot of
papers
including some in nature on the effects
of
reflective self-inquiry and meditation
on things like
telomeres that work was done in
collaboration with
elizabeth blackmon who's a nobel
laureate also in biology and physics and
she had never heard of what i do and i
convinced her to do the study
and once the study was completed over
one week of a reflective mindfulness
transcendent experience the level of
telomerase went up by
40 percent and that had never been seen
gene expression changed that had never
been seen we've come a long way
through science my only question is
and life as we know it wouldn't be
possible without science
we if we didn't have a vaccine right now
maybe the whole human population would
be at risk
of a pandemic and that's happened in the
past so science is the biggest
best adventure we've taken as human
beings it's part of our revolution
but uh is it the only
way of knowing what we call truth or
fundamental reality that's a whole
different question you know so you made
the distinction
earlier between science which is a
methodology
theory experiment
observation validation falsification
and it progresses every day we learn
something new
and we realize that something we thought
was we knew
is not new so you know the science is
that way
the best story also because it's willing
to change
it's not so dogmatic but scientism
becomes a religion it says this is the
only way to
know the truth including myself that
this is the only way to understand why
we
suffer why we grow old why we die
why we fear death why we fall in love
why we have longing
aspiration creativity vision
insight inspiration you know
until i know that the dance of molecules
and particles and
force fields and gravity can do this i
also rely on my inner practice
and reflections who am i that wants to
understand science
what am i that wants to understand the
brain
what am i that wants to understand the
cosmos now you can say i'm a cosmologist
but that's your train
who are you before you were a
cosmologist why did you even choose to
go into cosmology
so you know there's a part of us that is
full of mystery full of wonder
full of awe full of questions
full of doubts full of fears full of
aspirations full of longings
i want to know what that is and then i
want to see how that corresponds
to the experience of science which is
what's going on what's out there and i'm
asking
yes but who's asking questions who wants
to know
and why yeah i think about science as
even the hard sciences as social science
in that uh science is done by people we
we have
some hopes and actually some progress in
artificial intelligence and as you and i
and frank wilcheck and leonard milano
talked about last week
i'm most interested not in artificial
intelligence i think intelligence
is overrated sometimes and i'll give
some examples of that if you like but
uh but really wisdom is an in short
supply and wisdom
is the pinnacle of science i think of of
you know my computer has a lot of
knowledge
and in fact science itself means
knowledge but i think of actual
practical science where it
impacts daily life as a process and that
is wisdom based
and wisdom is very different from
knowledge so
science being a social enterprise that
means that it's done by human beings
and human beings have fallacies flaws
biases and prejudices
some of which are inherent some of which
are invidious
that they are poisonous to the human
population i can think of
several scientists including james
watson
william shockley the inventor of the
transistor these people
uh were incredibly brilliant both nobel
laureates
and both advocated in some form or
another for
philosophies that are eugenic in nature
and or discriminatory prejudice bias and
still to this day in the case of watson
uh it's really uh you know kind of
outrageous that he's still
making such statements but anyway
science is done by human beings we have
flaws but i want to ask you a question
that's really been plaguing me
since i read several of your books but
but in particular you are the universe
asserts that
effectively consciousness is a
distributed
uh property and it is the result
of matter as you asked frank wilcek you
said can
matter create mind what is your answer
to that question
does matter create mind or does mind
create matter
or something completely different
something completely different
and since you asked about wisdom
let me tell you how i think about wisdom
i think of
[Music]
wisdom being very different from
knowledge knowledge being very different
from
information and information being very
different
from data so today the data would be
maybe it's 65 degrees
centigrade fahrenheit in san diego
the information would be well
it's a pleasant day and such and such
activities are possible the knowledge
would be
what should i choose to do with this
weather
and the wisdom would be does this
nurture
the experience of
sentience or life and
that is in my mind the hierarchy
wisdom is the top of the pinnacle if
if you have knowledge without wisdom
knowledge can be diabolical
as you just said we have atom bombs we
have climate change we have extinction
of species
we have mechanized death we have cyber
warfare
etc etcetera you name it that's
also an aspect of knowledge but it's not
an aspect of wisdom
with the same knowledge we could
actually create more peaceful just
sustainable healthier and joyful work
same knowledge same information same
data
but a different awareness a different
consciousness so wisdom is the totality
of consciousness
that supports what i call
evolution but when i call evolution i
mean evolution of consciousness into
expansion of awareness into how
we know what we know or what are our
modes of knowing
so when i go in that direction then
i begin to say that we need a
conversation between those who are
looking out there
and those who are asking questions of
themselves
because the scientific method only gives
us
knowledge of a species specific
perception and cognition
species specific perception and
cognition now when we spoke to
um to frank wilcheck he says
don't underestimate the properties of
matter
so you just ask them does matter create
mind
now where i'm coming from brian and this
is where i get into trouble
with the scientists i don't believe in
the existence of matter
i think matter is a human
construct for a species specific
perception and its interpretation now
it's a very useful construct
right because we
we are experiencing what we call matter
all the time
including our own bodies okay including
our own bodies but then as we look
into the deeper nature of matter as even
frank said
don't underestimate matter it becomes
more and more and more ephemeral it
becomes
more and more transient it becomes more
and more
ungraspable you need a you need a hadron
collider to
observe a higgs boson which has a life
of
10 to the power of minus 22 seconds
so it's you know you need all this
technology to see something
which by the time you observe it it
doesn't even exist
and then we say this gives mass to the
universe and it does
now here is the interesting thing it
doesn't matter what you call it
this mysterious entity you can call it
matter
but if we believe that mata does all the
things that you know frank said
it does include great models of matter
then matter is god i mean if matter can
think visualize long aspire
then matter is god and it's fine call it
matter doesn't matter you can call it
einsoft
somebody else can call it whatever but
this is the mystery that matter
ultimately turns out to be
non-material and what about the
experiences of other species what about
the experience
of an insect with a hundred eyes or a
snake that navigates through
infrared or a butterfly that senses
ultraviolet or a chameleon whose
eyeballs swivel on two different axes
what does the world look like to a
chameleon
i can't even remotely imagine that
experience
so why is the human experience absolute
and human constructs absolute when we
made them up
we made up the story of money we made
wall street we made latitude
we made up greenwich mean time why not
botswana meantime
so you know we have all these constructs
we embed ourselves in these constructs
and then we say that's reality but no
that's not reality it's
partial yet so i want to dig deeper into
that because i think it's
uh it's incredibly succinct in a way and
it's
open to many different interpretations
and
i hate when people misinterpret me and
my guest i want to ask you a question
um and we maybe have discussed this in
the past do you believe that
triangles exist like do triangles have
the same status
as matter in deepak's mind
so in my mind existence
is a better word for
reality existence
because ex by the way that i didn't make
that up it comes from my tradition of
contemplative inquiry
so existence means anything that exists
this phone exists
a triangle exists as
at least in my in my experience okay
a circle exists in my experience
this body exists in my experience but
thoughts exist in my experience
feelings existed in my experience
imagination
exists in my experience creativity
exists in my experience
emotions exist in my experience so
existence is
anything that appears on the screen of
consciousness
including triangles and galaxies and
atoms and molecules
but also thoughts so i don't make a
distinction between mind and matter
they are complementary aspects
of a deeper reality which is neither
mind
nor matter what is that deeper reality
it's formless
it has no form so how can i say that
because if it had a form
if i would be able to see it it doesn't
have a foreign well
i think i'm realizing why you might be
controversial to scientists and the
reason why
involves um have you ever heard of the
concept the god of the gaps
yes so i think that sometimes scientists
look at you
and what you um what you propose as sort
of
science of the gaps or consciousness of
the gaps in other words
whatever cannot be explained or defined
without ultimate reductionism becomes
evidence of experience consciousness
emotions however you like and i once did
an exercise somebody told me if you go
to wikipedia the source of all
scientific wisdom and knowledge
and you go even click on deepak chopra i
don't care click on brian keating
and you click keep clicking the first
word in every wikipedia page
eventually the you will come down the
rabbit hole of recursion
and you will get to philosophy in other
words
these concepts exist in in the mind
philosophical means love of wisdom right
so i think that sometimes you're
perceived as
being um overawed by the power of
something that's hard to define if even
wikipedia can't define
what consciousness is this is a truly
hard problem of consciousness
and you and i have spoken along with
noam chomsky and stuart hammerhoff
and sir roger penrose recent winner of
the nobel prize and
we talk about consciousness and it seems
to me the lack of
universal definitions for something is a
sign that
maybe it's not within human uh um
purview to explain for example you can
talk to somebody about abortion
incredibly complicated incredibly
difficult
emotional subject and you can say to
them i can make you
and i agree on it even if i'm pro-life
and you're pro-choice i can say
a baby doesn't exist before the parents
met before the parents were even in the
same
life lifetime and similarly a baby
exists
after it's born and is in the hospital
delivery room between those two states
is a schrodinger cat-like object which
is in a superposition but not according
to science but according to perception
and i feel like consciousness is like
that as well and so
you know it's it's almost as useless in
some sense to me and i want you to prove
me wrong
to think about consciousness because we
can't even come to a definition
that is universally agreed upon and so
therefore people project
their hostility to you and your and your
definition of consciousness and that's
why i think
that you're held with some disregard in
the scientific community
it's a 100 true on the other hand
the definitions of consciousness and
scientific circles
are ambiguous but they're not uneven in
philosophical circles they're ambiguous
but not for those of us who come from
spiritual traditions where consciousness
is the only reality
so if you want a definition of
consciousness here it is
consciousness is the knowing element in
every experience
we are having that experience right now
because we are conscious beings
okay it's the knowing element it's not
just
that i know i know that i know so
consciousness also is self awareness
consciousness is that in which all
experience occurs
i think you'll agree that this
experience is occurring in consciousness
consciousness is that and what in which
all experience
is known i think you will agree that we
know
that we are having this experience and
the last part is difficult consciousness
is that
out of which all experience is made
so sound is a perception
which is a modified form of
consciousness so is seen
so is hearing so it's tasting so it's
swelling so it's thinking so it's
feeling so is imagining
so it's all perceptual activity in
consciousness
that allows us to create the constructs
of mind and matter
and consciousness itself is in the gap
right now
if i wasn't going to see if i closed my
eyes
imagine the empire state building then i
closed
keep my eyes closed imagine the face of
my mother
okay now imagine wall street now
imagine listening to john lennon's
imagine how did you do that
explain to me scientifically how did you
create the image
of the milky way galaxy just by thinking
about it
or you think of a rose you have to
return
to the formless to the gap in you
in order to have that experience so
between every thought there's a gap
if there wasn't this would be
okay the fact that there's syntax
grammar
sequential unfoldment of ideas means
that between
every idea there's a gap between every
perception there's a gap between every
sensation
there's a gap between every thought
there's a gap
between every image there's a gap and
the gap is where all the action is
now if i wanted to give you an
explanation of the gap in scientific
terms
and risk myself because that's what i
get
ridiculed the gap is potential
it's before your father looked at your
mother
with a gleam in his eyes okay
that was in the gap the potential for
brian
to emerge nine months later after
your dad looked at your mother with that
longing that's what i called my my
personal big bang
your personal big bag so you existed as
potential
in your father and your mother and like
that
everything exists in potential there's
the form and there's formless there's
the manifest there's the unmanifest
there's the perceived there's the
unperceived and there are
complementarities reductionism
lets me look at the particular but
holism
lets me understand what is actually
going
on even if i look at my own body look at
my own body
my blood pressure my heart rate my
immune system my endocrine system
they're all instantly correlated there's
no explanation
for why feedback loops correlate with
other feedback loops
it seems to me non-local now of course
if i say that again i get ridiculous
what does the gap contain it contains
infinite possibilities
unpredictable it makes quantum leaps of
creativity and imagination you had
when i asked you to think of john
lennon's song and think of your mother
and then think of the
rainbow you took quantum leaps between
one image and another you didn't travel
from one to the other
it is indeterminate it is the source of
attention and intention and it is
creative
so where consciousness is fundamental is
the creative
impulse of evolution that gives rise
to perceptions and interpretations of
perceptions through which we
create models of reality i think we need
to understand
both the formless and that which has
formed
without the gap you can't have the
space-time event
space-time events are punctuations
and syntax of the gap as i told you when
we were setting this up
uh and then talking with your assistant
uh who i love
uh i said i want to call this episode
the deepak uh of the into the impossible
podcast
uh with yours truly dr brian keating and
dr deepak chopra who's a real doctor not
like me
uh but uh but i want to call it sensors
and sensibility
because uh their famous book sense and
sensibility is sort of reminiscent
of what we do as human beings but i'm an
experimental physicist
i think i don't know how many
experimental physicists you've had in
contact with you've
certainly known a lot of uh theoretical
physicists like frank wilcex or roger
penrose you even knew stephen hawking
you know leonard milad now and you know
many other people and you've debated
people
because you have a extremely rare gift
which is that you're eloquent and
courageous and your
eloquence will often be uh be found
most most noticeably when you are
being humble as you were on the stage at
caltech when you first were confronted
by this
uh by this you know somewhat uh somewhat
obscepis leonard malod now uh telling
you that you don't know about quantum
mechanics and i'll teach you about
quantum mechanics and you were humble
enough to accept that challenge
deepak to say um would you like to have
a short course in quantum mechanics
sometimes so that we can straighten out
your
slightly misuse of quantum
notation
i thank you i would be honored sir and i
accept your offer with great gratitude
and uh i would like to be educated so i
can be clearer in my
in my dialogue
[Music]
and we'll talk later about how arthur c
clarke said the only way to know the
limits of what is possible
is to venture beyond those limits into
the impossible and that's the name of
this podcast but anyway
i want to defend the sensor community so
i am an experimental physicist i build
senses because they augment
the reality that i perceive in that they
transmutate
uh things that are in principle
unobservable like voltage
voltage is not a sensor we don't have a
sensory organ for voltage
sharks do but there there are also
sensors that no animal has a sensor for
such as neutrinos that experimental
colleagues of mine
have detected as they propagate from the
bowels of a supernova
explosion literally millions of light
years away to our telescopes here on
earth
and we use those to augment the first
thing that frank said on our live stream
and i'll have a link to it up here
or maybe i'll put it over here when
you're all watching this video
the first thing that frank said uh i
noticed he was slightly defensive
when we got on the call last week and
he's
he's an exceptional human being and i've
noticed this with all my conversations
with nobel prize winners
uh that they uh except for sir roger
penrose he's he's
extremely um you know risk uh risk
fillick he loves to take on new risky
projects but
uh let me just say with frank the first
thing he said is well
you know consciousness doesn't have this
role and spirituality doesn't have this
role because there's no
detector that you have to tell the
operator
thereof that oh i was thinking about uh
about god at this moment or i was
thinking about this
are there things that are extra sensory
in that we believe that they that they
are operative in the universe from your
perspective
consciousness potentially uh that have
an effect
and could they be measured using tools
in a laboratory because i think that
would go a very long way
towards uh proving to whatever extent
such a thing is possible
but more accurately as you mentioned
falsifying
maybe even deepak the mark of a good
scientist that you are
would be to accept the falsification
that consciousness
can't be measured do you think
consciousness is susceptible
to the measurement technologies that my
students and i employ in our
laboratories
no because consciousness is what
measures
consciousness is what measures
consciousness conceives
governs constructs and becomes what it
measures
so let me explain that for a moment
consciousness is
not measurable because
it is not observable it is actually the
basis
of observing when you do science
experiments are conceived in
consciousness
they are designed in consciousness
theories are constructed
in consciousness observations are made
in consciousness
you cannot verify consciousness as an
object
because the object itself is a
perceptual interpretation
do you mean a bias like i'm looking for
gravitational waves from
inspiring black holes and therefore that
constrains the answers i can get or do
you mean
yes every observation is a selective
observation
and in order to observe one thing you
have to ignore
everything else so what about uh what
about serendipitous discoveries like the
universe is accelerating in its
expansion well
that was not the actually that was the
opposite of what the observers
expected to observe where was the
surrender
understood where was the concept of
serendipity
itself what is serendipity
what is correlation these are all human
concepts
for modes of knowing and experience in
consciousness
so you see this is the problem with the
reductionism
is we are only looking at what's out
there we are never
asking what is it that is observing
so consciousness is the observer the
process of observation
and that which is observed simultaneous
you need all three
you need that observer you need a mode
of observation
and then you need something that is
known as the observed
and consciousness is all of those before
it modifies itself into experience which
then we construct models of so
even the human body is the model in
consciousness
there's no such thing as a human body in
my opinion because
you know when we talk about human body
we think of it as a noun
but actually the human body is a verb it
started as a fertilized ovum it'll end
in depth
so if you say i am my body you have to
define which one
am i the fertilized egg am i the zygote
am i the embryo
am i the baby am i the toddler am i the
teenager
am i the middle aged guy worried about
impotence am i the only guy worried
about death which one
am i so you see as soon as i make a
material construct
of anything i have a problem every form
turns out to be a phenomenon and the
phenomenon
is an interpretation of perception and
cognition
in human consciousness not in bacterial
consciousness
not in the consciousness of a giraffe
even the idea of a giraffe is in human
consciousness
that giraffe doesn't know it's called a
giraffe a proton doesn't know it's
called a proton the milky way galaxy
doesn't know it's called a
milky way galaxy so when i see an object
and brian you have to listen to this
carefully
i'm not seeing the object i'm seeing
everything
other than what the object is you know
immanuel kant said
we see only the surface we don't know
the thing in itself
we never know the thing in itself now of
course if you ask frank you'll say it's
mass charge
and and momentum or spin okay but who
came up with that concept
on what basis you cannot as max planck
said
get behind consciousness right
i think so i think all these things and
i think consciousness is not alone i
think there are chicken and egg
type problems oh by the way deepak my
son one of my sons came up with the
solution
to determine which came first the
chicken
neither that their complementarities
again you know no
no you're wrong you're absolutely wrong
deepak my son
went to amazon.com he ordered a chicken
and he ordered an egg
and the egg came first okay good
i get it well i do agree with you that
these are
um you know incredibly vexing problems i
i note though that you must have
a code in which you live your life i
know you have a code i have a code
that's very different from yours
i'm a torah practicing jew and it has a
very different perspective
on life and the meaning and the
hierarchy of life
we as jews put human life at the apex
and that is how i believe we can define
an absolute sense of morality
in the absence of which i don't think
you can sam harris has said
essentially you could get all the laws
of of you know of morality and and how
uh what is truly you know right not the
laws of ethics i think the golden rule
the silver rule those are
kind of universally accepted in some
sense but morality
you know who is who is to say that you
know eating a potato
uh is the same is not the same as eating
a chicken
if you know i say they both have eyes uh
and i know you're you you practice
vegetarianism or veganism i forget which
one but but but the point is
uh in judaism we are not allowed to eat
a person
that's explicitly forbidden and yet we
are entitled to eat animals
and so my question to you is can this
notion of consciousness how does it
dovetail how does it allow one
to consume for their purposes
uh living material maybe even
unconscious material
uh and uh or conscious material rather
and what
on what basis do you in your practice
uh can you justify that so
human consciousness is the pinnacle
of the evolution of consciousness
is and all biological organisms are
conscious ages and
each conscious agent you know i'm using
terms
carefully right now because these are
loaded terms when you soul
spirit god ions of their loaded terms
the conscious agent is any
any sentience that is capable of
responding
to its environment or even making a
choice some
so we as humans have
the highest expression of that because
we are self-aware
and we have what is called explanat
explanatory power
you know we try to explain things um the
big bang okay so what caused the big
bang
what happened in blank epoch
uh are there laws of physics at the
blank scale of
geometry uh space-time geometry on and
on
why is mathematics so effective in
predicting the behavior of the physical
world
it's obvious that human consciousness
is at the pinnacle now as far as
violence
and in nature is concerned that's
another very interesting thing because
without
violence there wouldn't be the food
chain there would not be anything that
we call life
life is based on on
biological organisms eating each other
up
all the time so you know
without violence there's no life
but as we expand our awareness as we
become
and again i'm being very careful here
how i say this
human consciousness is almost god-like
it's divine it's diabolical it can
create
anything that it imagines it has already
created everything it imagines it can
also destroy
anything that is there so we are
as self-aware beings definitely
have divinity by divinity i mean
creative
power creative power we can you know
frank said the other day i can with my
thoughts i can move my
my arm but i can't move your arm but i
can
if i tell you to move your arm you'll do
you're right right
yeah also as i'm speaking to you right
now i'm moving molecules in your brain
i'm moving networks uh neural networks
in your brain
i'm moving all kinds of things dopamine
serotonin
oxytocin depending on the conversation
or moving a lot of viewers to my youtube
channel
and all these people are biologically
all these people
are biologically entangled with us all
these people
right this moment about everybody who is
listening to us
we are entangled in biology in mind
space
in consciousness space of course we're
calling it cyberspace
but the cyberspace is the vehicle for
our
limited bandwidth of experience as
human beings but as you said we can
extend that through scientific
experiment technology we are extending
what we call everyday reality
according to spiritual traditions
and monistic traditions monistic
idealism or monistic non-dualism
in those traditions the formless
potential
is the only reality everything else is
an
evanescent ephemeral transient
ungraspable experience that we
codify as mind matter and the universe
there's no such thing it's a human
construct
so i want to take a step from this
ethereal plane that we are on to
uh what we in hebrew called the talkless
the practical
the mundane but the important um how do
you organize your
life uh you're in your early 70s now
you've written uh dozens of books i
think you're writing a book with your
right hand
while we're talking right now that's how
productive deepak chopra today's guest
on the into the impossible podcast is
um when you were younger and you were
and you and your daughter
uh was young and uh you were starting
off in your career
how did you come to make choices on a
daily basis
um what i mean is between consumption
of information and production of new
ideas new creativity new collaborations
how did you handle the ties that you had
the obligations you have first of all to
your to your family first
um how do you deal with those um those
those
constraints and maintain your your
productivity so i'm asking two things uh
basically what's your daily ritual like
now
and how do you handle uh the guilt i
call it producer's guilt
that we have when we have to say no to
our toddler
in order to do something and we lie and
we say oh it's to make money
and that's going to help them but that's
a lie a lot of it's for ourself and our
own gratification of our ego so
what's your daily routine like number
one and number two
how do you handle saying no to the
people you love the most
i can answer those two questions but i
should tell you that
right through internship residency
fellowship neuroscience
neuroendocrinology
i was a driven person
ambitious and trying to be successful in
my career
okay now in the background ever since
the age of six
years of age i've been mystified
and troubled by the fact
that existence is so impermanent
so i remember when i was six years of
age
i was living with my grandparents and my
father was a cardiologist
and he was training in england and one
year we got a telegram
and the telegram was that my father had
become a fellow of the royal college of
physicians as a cardiologist in
post-colonial india that was a big deal
so my grandfather who was a world war
one
veteran indian went to the roof fired
some rounds
into the sky took me and my little
brother who later became the dean of
medical education at harvard medical
school
my brother was four years i was six
years he took us to the carnival
took us to a movie called alibaba and
the 40 thieves
took us out for dinner and then in the
middle of the night he died
and the next day he was taken to
cremation
and one of my uncles said what is a
human being
last night he was
[Music]
celebrating with the kids his son had
become a member of the royal college of
physicians
and today he's a bunch of ashes in that
jar
and i had at the age of six years my
first existential crisis
my little brother who as i said became
the dean of education at harvard
his skin started peeling went to every
doctor in the world
nobody could make a diagnosis there was
a healer
who said he's feeling vulnerable so he's
shedding his skin
metaphorically when his parents come
back he'll be fine
and that's exactly what happened so i
think in retrospect that was my first
existential crisis and also my first
understanding of
mind and body as being inseparable
i went to medical school for that reason
but when you go to medical
school the first lesson is anatomy you
see a dead body
you're supposed to understand life by
looking at a dead body but it gets
better
physiology biochemistry now mathematics
all
understanding biology so i was very
troubled
all my life by impermanence as a doctor
i saw grief within one hour i saw people
going through the stages of death the
heart attack so
anger denial hostility and then
fear and then helplessness and then
resignation
and then deaths and i i felt
deep compassion for human suffering deep
deep compassion for human suffering so
what is my life right now
the number one thing in my life is
all life is sacred all life
is sacred we live in the internet trolls
who call you
uh hack and uh sacred sacred they're
doing the best
they can from the conditioned mind even
trump
is doing the best he can from where he
is in his awareness so there is no other
pursuit
than expanding our awareness in science
in the arts
in sociology in human relationships
in emotional connections there is no
bigger
endeavor wisdom is the sanctity of
life having said that we have to eat
and therefore we minimize violence
that's why i'm a vegetarian
i minimize violence knowing that i'm
still violent
in my eating habits at some level
i also realized that as a human being
99.9
of the inflammation in my body is
bacterial it's microbes
i i revere the sanctity of life of
microbes including
foreign because without microbes
you and i wouldn't be having this
conversation you know
so this holism makes me
feel sacred now what's my daily routine
first 25 years
my tradition maximum education
second time 25 years maximum success
third 25 years maximum giving back
now i'm entering my fourth stage
that is preparation for death and
so i very joyfully celebrate
impermanence i ask myself every day
who is it that's going to die and i
can't answer the question
what is going to die because my body as
an embryo is dead
already my body as a teenager is dead
already
i don't have the personality of a 15
year old
what is going to die what is my identity
i think that's the biggest
crisis of existence what is identity
and this is how i keep myself busy right
now
i have no personal motivation in the
world honestly i have no personal
ambition
in the world honestly my only goal right
now
is to prepare for the impermanence
of existence as i know it and to be
at peace with it and see how i can
realize my true nature
independent of science or philosophy
or theology or any human construct
who am i without constructs that is my
own quest
well i don't think i've ever heard you
say it so succinctly but i think that
that's
a very uh extremely deep and meaningful
way to think about life and i wonder yes
in the
in the early stages of life and you know
producing and growing and maximum
maximizing the education there is one
trait which i wonder if you
would agree with me on that you can
maintain at all four of those
25-year quarter century marks and that
is curiosity
and i see that in you i see that um i
once heard you know somebody
maybe it was warren buffett or maybe
somebody talking about warren buffett
they said
you know i can't have warren buffett's
uh i can't have his wealth
just by thinking about having wealth but
i can be
as satisfied with what i have as what he
is satisfied with with what he has
uh but also i can be as uh ethical as he
is
as moral as he is to whatever i don't
know him personally but
but to whatever extent you think that he
is uh and then
i add to that you can be as curious as
he is or as anybody is
and i think that that is a hallmark of
who you are is this relentless
passion for curiosity do you believe
that life
is possible to extend not physically
but through uh things like
transcendental meditation and i
the first time i met you i had a lot of
temerity i said deepak
i need a mantra i've tried
transcendental meditation i can't do it
i've tried
mindful meditation i can't do it can you
give me a mantra
that will stick and you said you shmuck
so i've been doing that i've been saying
you schmuck
i do it if no i'm just kidding i don't
do that but um
if you if you had uh to guess at
the actual way that life can be extended
i happen to think i know the answer to
how
one can extend one's life to whatever
way we have of teleporting our
physical and mental nature into the
future i have a proposal for that
uh but i'm more interested in your
proposal how can i extend my life
on a daily basis and add more meaning to
my life through
a daily practice through meditation what
what do you recommend for those of us
who are
live a lot up here and and find it hard
to get out
of our doubting you know kind of monkey
mind uh perspective
from a spiritual perspective you extend
life by
number by the way curiosity of course is
a trait of all sentient beings not just
humans
you look at a baby you look at a mouse
you look at a cat they're all curious
humans don't go a little bit beyond that
they want explanations for their
curiosity that's a human and without
that explanatory part there wouldn't be
human civilization
that is a trait of consciousness itself
curiosity and explanatory power
and modeling is a trait of human
consciousness
now extension of life from a spiritual
perspective
number one eat less number two
breathe slowly take your time to breathe
number three speak less
and number four quieten your mind
so it's at all levels material
emotional physiological
and ultimately at the level of pure
self-awareness
or transcendence now our studies
which we have just mentioned with
elizabeth blackburn and others
show that actually these practices
extend life telomerase level went up by
40 percent all the genes
that are responsible for homeostasis so
self-regulation went up
some 17 fold over baseline all the genes
that were responsible for inflammation
and chronic illness including heart
disease and diabetes went out
so one of our collaborators in the study
was from mount sinai in new york
and he was presenting the sudden he was
showing this uh
slide and he was trying you know
telomeres went up
and gene expression went in the
direction of poker stasis
and away from inflammation
so somebody in the audience he said dr
shah his name is eric chad
he said do you meditate he said no
he said are you planning to we said no
he said why not you just showed us the
data he said yeah i'm going to figure
out how to make drugs out of this
so actually he left mount sinai
he's now using the ips of the studies to
actually
develop drugs out of the experience of
meditation
so you know there's room for everyone
here there's room for the technologist
there's room for the reductionist i
don't think
there's any drug that could create the
synchronistic holistic
correlated symphony
of events in the body other than
consciousness
no drug can do that because the drug is
one element
in the whole framework of
inseparable coherence yeah
you might call it creativity you might
call it
entanglement you might call it
superposition of ideas
whatever you want to call it there's a
deep
mystery at the heart of creation and
that mystery
is the mystery of who am i so if i've
ended up with another galaxy
or another planet my first question
would be
what am i doing here and why am i here
and
is what i'm perceiving
a construct in my mind an experience of
perceptual activity
did awareness travel awareness never
travels awareness is just
is it creates models and stories and
constructs and perceptions and
sensations and images and feelings and
thoughts
but that's why i am the mystery
and without knowing my mystery there is
no other mystery
right that's as walt whitman said do i
contradict myself
yes very well then i contain multitudes
and i think you have a great deal of
multitudes in you not just the
microbes that you spoke about earlier
but uh
a refreshing breadth of creative ideas
and curiosity and not only um you know
just just as a side light highlight
rather
what you said about curiosity yeah cats
have it and the the most
mendacious or or you know an unfortunate
aspect of associating cats in curiosity
especially with children as nobel prize
winning physicist
barry barrich said on the podcast i'll
put it up here he said that
curiosity killed the cat sends an awful
message to young children
that you shouldn't be curious that you
should suppress it and actually
one of your fellow md's and
practitioners of meditation dr judson
brewer
at my alma mater brown university he
actually believes that curiosity can
uh can be responsible for things like
addiction
breaking a dick addictions smoking even
drug use
even reducing food and cravings for food
so i like to say i
thanks to him and curiosity i was able
to drop five pounds from my double chin
to my belly so that's been very helpful
to me i thank him
i want to conclude uh with uh with a a
very brief
take from you about this article that
was presented by the new york times uh
back in october and it was about
uh the title is how how to disagree like
an adult
according to deepak chopra they they
they call you a new age celebrity which
i think is
is is kind of nonsense i do love the
pictures uh which depict uh torrey pines
glider port
and you and your sandals perched
precariously i'll put a link to that
in the show notes below but i i really
enjoyed this piece and i think that we
want to have more conversations
with other scientists using this
framework that you lay out and i'm just
going to put them on there and say
if you only uh if you only could apply
one of these principles that you put
out there ranging from choose if you
want to engage
engage first you have to listen three
learn about the other person's values
four try awareness and pause five don't
engage in black and white thinking
and when confronted stop take a deep
breath smile
and then make a choice which of those if
you only could choose one
or maybe it's impossible to only choose
one what is the most important
of deepak's uh seven commandments here
are eight commandments maybe they're
nine nine commandments
there's only one right before you react
press press the pause button step into
the gap
and watch your reaction to react that
will break the circus
yes instead of being reactive pause
and observe your reaction to react
that'll break the circuit
and by the way curiosity didn't kill the
cat
your curiosity allowed you to determine
whether it was dead or alive
i say marie curie killed the cat because
the geiger counter goes off because of
her
laws okay the last segment that we have
on the into the impossible podcast is
the final three questions
if you have just a couple more minutes
deepak i would love to ask you these
questions
i enjoyed this very much brian and thank
you for not ridiculing me
i would never do that i have uh respect
for you not only because i know you
personally
uh but i respect your humility i think
you are a science
scientist in the way that you approach
these things in the research that you're
doing as you point out as well
i i could spend all day with you but i
know you're extremely busy so i'm just
going to finish up by asking
these questions that i ask all my guests
i'm in the office of jeff burbidge who
is
one of the greatest astrophysicists of
the previous
previous millennium century and he was a
close colleague of giant narlikar
who is in india to this day in pune and
he started their cosmology center
i asked him this question i want to ask
you this question now deepak
in your ethical will in your zava ah
what you want to communicate to future
generations not material form
not in tangible physical form because we
know that impermanence of that
what would you put in your ethical will
that you want to communicate to your
biological offspring but also your
ideological offspring
so i would say on the level of feeling
the ethics is empathy compassion
love joy equinimity
and kindness and alleviation of
suffering
on the emotional level on the
intellectual level
the seeking always of truth goodness
beauty
harmony curiosity
wonder and humility
and before you say what's going on
always asking
who's asking very good
the next question is also about the
future and it connects to
the movie 2001 a space odyssey by
kubrick
and this movie have you seen the movie
2001 yes
so the opening scene features these
hominids and they're on the
plains of the savannah of africa and
they're exploring and they come upon
this huge
monolith and they don't know what to do
with it they hit it with their bones and
they try to do stuff to it nothing
happens then later
uh thousands millions of years later we
come up with a
uh we come up to find that human beings
have
a have a encounter
the same monolith structure but on the
surface of the moon
so now they've developed technology
maybe far in advance
of of the hominids certainly but maybe
far short of what the aliens wanted us
to encode
my question for you is if you had a time
capsule
like these monoliths that would last for
a billion years
what would you inscribe upon it what
would you put within it
knowing that it would last for
essentially the remainder of
existence so brian across
the seas of both outer space
which you explore and inner space which
i
explore across the seas of space
inner and outer are the raw materials
of a new imagination we have a future
that even homer never imagined
we have a future that no one ever
imagined i can
just tell you that i can see in a few
less than a millennium a less than a
century
seeding intergalactic space
and planets with human life and life of
all kinds
with just information technology using
information dna sequential codes
teleportation to create biospheres
in exoplanets i see adventures
that will understand what we understand
here
theoretically right now whether it's
teleportation
or you know extra sensory perception
which we are already doing right now
this is extra sensory perception
you know through zoom or whatever so i
see adventures of imagination
actualizing into reality that are at the
moment
unimaginable you know rumi the poet said
when i die
i will soar with angels but when i die
to the angels what i shall become you
cannot imagine
so for us to see the future
in the distance we don't even have the
imagination yet
very good we can't even conceive upon
that we're like those uh
alleged tribes in in south america when
they come upon
a boat they can't visualize what it
means
and they don't process it because their
awareness has not yet
advanced but that doesn't necessarily
impute superiority of course so the last
question
that i ask all my guest epoch now
involves going to the past
and it involves essentially life advice
to your former self
when you were getting maximum education
maximum
success uh maybe in your 20s
or so the life advice you'd give and
it's encapsulated
in the name of this podcast so arthur
clark
had many different maxims i already said
one of them is
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
and that's actually read in his own
voice at the opening of each of one
of the into the impossible podcast his
second law
was that for every expert there's an
equal and
opposite expert and his third law
is the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
that's how i got the name of this
podcast so i want to ask you
when you were a 20 year old or a 30 year
old what
life advice would you most benefit uh
from
knowing to allow you to have the courage
to go
into the impossible see if i had given
myself that advice to
my 20 year old i wouldn't have listened
to myself
you know i was 20 years old i was
smoking cigarettes
enjoying alcohol dating girls
getting stressed about my exams
wondering where i could get my
internship
no advice would have helped me at every
stage of life
there is what you do is what you do now
in hindsight
i don't regret it all you know every
stage is a learning stage
the only thing i would say is the
impossible is just a word
for something that hasn't happened yet
that's it and in fact the impossible
is the field of all possibilities the
impossible
is the infinite impossible
is whatever is not possible today
is going to be possible tomorrow i may
not live to see
but
[Music]
creativity and consciousness and
awareness
have no limitations that's the
definition of infinity infinity is not a
number it just means
no limits reminds me of what i believe
eleanor roosevelt said the word
impossible really means i'm possible
that's very good i loved it well deepak
uh i love what you do
i love your spirit i love your courage
and i love your curious
uh and mercurius nature that just acts
as an inspiration
not just for me but for millions of
people around the world that you've
helped you've healed
uh you've done tremendous good in the
world and i only hope to
do a fraction of that with your uh
guidance as an
inspiration to me and uh i've certainly
benefited from it so thank you so much
for going into the impossible
stay well and stay in touch thank you
brian i hope we meet soon after this
madness is over and have some fun
together
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
[Music]
magic
[Music]
[Music]
shalom is the perfect mantra to
transcend
not schmuck shalom okay
now you heard it here nobody else can
use that out there it's only private
personal
for brian keating
you